MICHAEL ANTON:
Welcome, everyone,
to our second panel of the day,
of the morning on the future
of the Republican Party.
My name is Michael Anton.
I am lecturer and research
fellow at the Kirby Center,
of Hillsdale College's Kirby
Center here in Washington, DC,
just a few miles from here,
where, as you heard last night,
we are launching a brand
new program this week,
a graduate school for
statesmanship and politics.
And it's actually
already underway.
We've got some students
there studying,
and we expect this to grow
into something really,
really big and important.
And I'm excited to
be a part of it.
I'm really excited
to be a part of it.
It's one of the reasons
that I wanted to come here,
and was very glad when I
was hired to come here.
So I know all three of
the people in this panel.
So it'll be very easy for me to
introduce them without notes.
David Azerrad is a fellow at
the Heritage Foundation, a dear
friend of mine, for
what that's worth.
He may want to disavow it.
And he's been spending a lot of
his time lately thinking deeply
about partisan politics, and
particularly the intersection
of identity politics
and what effect
that has on the American
two-party system
and on the political
system more broadly.
Allen Guelzo is a longtime
historian and professor
at Gettysburg College who
has also recently taken up
an affiliation with
Princeton University.
So that institution has
risen in my estimation
by the nature of that hire.
I can think of few
people, especially
as an old student
of Lincoln myself,
I think of few people
better equipped
to talk about the future
of the Republican Party
simply because I think there's
hardly a person on Earth,
if there is anyone, who
knows more about the origins
and the history of
the Republican Party
than Professor Guelzo.
And therefore, he's
very well positioned
to speak about its future.
He's also, if you've never heard
him speak, every speech he does
is a bit of performance
art in the best sense.
I don't know how he
does it because there's
no tapes of these
19th century orators.
But I imagine when I hear him--
I remember the first
time I heard him
I was quite blown
away by how polished,
practiced, and really
impactful it was--
that somehow he unearthed
tapes before recording devices
were even invented,
and he learned
how the speakers of the
past traded in their art.
And I was quite amazed, and
I think you probably will be,
too.
Henry Olsen, another dear
friend of mine for many years,
I think he's here
for a lot of reasons,
but one overarching
reason is there's just
nobody who better understands
the political tides
and currents at a very
granular, district by district,
percentage points numbers level.
And he can take hard, confusing,
maybe even intimidating
and boring data and
make it extremely
accessible and
understandable, in terms
that an audience that
maybe doesn't want to
swim around in spreadsheets
all day looking at numbers.
Those eyes might
glaze over at that.
I would include myself in that.
He can take that and put it
into words in a way that just
makes sense of all of that.
And just simply
the best election
watcher I know right now.
I would say also, he's a fellow
at the Ethics and Public Policy
Center, and he writes a daily
column in the Washington Post.
Again, another reason to
think slightly more highly
of that institution, which
is, if you want to know,
if you want to know really
what's going on in the run
up to the 2020 election in
detail, follow that column.
So I am the chair, and I think
I have fulfilled my duties.
My only other duty is to make
sure everybody stays on time.
That means I'm going to give
them the hook if they go over.
We are going in
the order you see.
That means Mr. Azerrad
is your first speaker.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID AZERRAD: Thank
you, Mike, and thank you
to Hillsdale for inviting me.
It's quite an honor
to be participating
in this Constitution
Day celebration.
I was not so lucky as
to go to Hillsdale.
They don't have a campus in
Canada last time I checked.
But I did go to grad school
at the University of Dallas,
where I had the
pleasure of studying
under Tom West
and RJ [INAUDIBLE]
and with Kevin Slack.
I then worked under Matt
Spalding at the Heritage
Foundation for three years.
And over the years
at Heritage, I've
had the pleasure of teaching
many Hillsdale interns,
and I'm always impressed by how
well their minds and character
are well-formed.
Most universities,
it seems to me,
are in the business of
delivering credentials.
Hillsdale is in the
business of ensuring
that they get an education.
Regrettably, I was
not asked to talk
about the life of
the mind, but to deal
in much less dignified
subject, albeit one
that is quite important, namely
the future of the Republican
Party.
As I see it, there is
a fundamental asymmetry
between our two political
parties in America.
I'll state the matter bluntly so
as to highlight the difference.
The Republican Party wants
to win elections in order
to enact Republican policies,
whereas the Democratic Party
wants to win elections to ensure
that the Republican Party never
wins another election.
The Democrats, and the
left more generally,
have flipped von Clausewitz's
maxim on its head.
Politics for them
is the continuation
of war by other means.
The goal is to defeat the enemy.
Now, in the immediate
sense, the enemy
is defined as the
Republican Party, especially
the racist orange man who
was installed by the Russians
in the White House.
But Trump and the GOP
find their support
amongst all of the deplorables
who cling to their guns
and their religion,
conservative media, and all
of the institutions
of the vast right wing
conspiracy that occupies
the progressive imagination.
They, too, must be
brought to heel.
These enemies need
not be annihilated,
but they must be subdued.
The GOP and the
right may continue
to exist, but only as a
controlled, neutered opposition
that does not challenge
in any meaningful way
the progressive project
to fundamentally transform
the United States of America
into a romanticized version
of Sweden.
I say romanticized because
Sweden has universal school
choice and private health
care, no elective late term
abortions or minimum
wage, and it does not
bestow birthright
citizenship upon the children
of illegal aliens.
This, however, never
figures in Bernie Sanders'
glowing accounts of the nation.
As a result of this
asymmetry, there
is a clarity of purpose,
a resolve, and dare I say,
a ruthlessness in
the Democratic Party
that one rarely finds
in the Republican Party.
They are at war with us.
They have openly said so.
But too many of us
prefer not to admit this.
They play to win
while we just play
maybe not to lose too badly.
I was at a dinner with
several prominent conservative
intellectuals in
Washington, DC, last month.
And the consensus
around the table
was we should use whatever
political power we now
have to enact policies,
like school choice, that
will shield us from what will
come once Elizabeth Warren
or Kamala Harris
become president.
Now, listen, this is not
a foolish way to think,
this I readily concede.
But here is the question
that I put to the table
and that I would put
to you this morning.
Do you think anyone on the
left ever thinks like this?
Do you think they ever
ask themselves, well,
what can we do to make sure
that they're not mean to us when
they win an election?
Of course they don't.
Because Democrats don't
think like losers.
Because Democrats are not
afraid of Republicans.
And can you blame them?
At most, the GOP will
thwart for a few years
their great ambitions, like
Medicare for all, amnesty
for all, or the Green New Deal.
But it's not like they have
to fear that the Republican
Party is ever going to repeal
any one of their major programs
once it's implemented.
Need I remind you that the
GOP promised for eight years
to repeal and replace
Obamacare, and when they finally
had the opportunity to
do so, they flinched.
The first order of business,
therefore, for the GOP--
if it wants to have a future--
is an attitude adjustment.
We need a more spirited
Republican Party, a Republican
Party that fights with
the same intensity
and clarity of purpose as
the Democratic Party does,
a Republican Party
that fights to win.
And this is one area where the
current figurehead of the party
has much to teach his
fellow Republicans.
Now in praising him, I am not
blind to his shortcomings.
President Trump's flaws
are readily apparent,
and let me remind you, they
have received more attention
than those of any other
president in American history.
He does, however, also
possess certain virtues
that are worthy of
emulation, chief of which
is his spiritedness.
The president may not always
pick his battles well,
nor does he always fight
them in the most prudent way,
or with decorum for
that matter, but no one
can question his will to fight.
This I suspect accounts
for much of his popularity
amongst the Republican base
and certain independents,
and it accounts for
much of the horror
he inspires in Democrats.
A Republican who fights
unapologetically?
What a sight!
This is not what we
have come to expect
from the party that gave us
Mitt Romney, Paul Ryan, and Jeb
Bush.
Now, I realize that
some of you may
find my counsel distasteful.
Wouldn't it be better,
you may ask, if, you know,
Trump and the GOP
didn't escalate things?
Wouldn't it be nicer if we had
a more mild-mannered person
at the head of the party?
I don't know, maybe a gentleman?
We are living in
turbulent times.
The country is in the
midst of a cold civil war,
and we are not dealing
with an opponent who
abides by the gentlemen's
code of conduct.
The times call for more
aggressive men and women.
Gentlemen are admirable
in many regards,
but they have their limitations.
A gentleman, for
example, will not
be comfortable humiliating
a woman in public.
This, you will admit,
poses a problem
if the woman in question
is Kamala Harris, Elizabeth
Warren, or who knows,
Michelle Obama.
Now ultimately, it's not
enough to want to fight.
You've got to fight
for the right things.
And it's not enough to
fight for the right things.
You've got to fight
through to victory.
So what should the
Republican Party fight for?
The immediate priority,
it seems to me,
is to prevent the Democratic
Party and their allies
on the left from
enacting policies
that will all but guarantee
democratic political hegemony.
They currently have their
sights set on three areas
to ensure that, and
these are further
restricting political
speech, transforming
the electoral
system, and changing
the demographics of the
country through continued
large-scale immigration.
Allow me to explain them.
First, on free speech,
America is currently
the only Western nation in the
world that has not criminalized
so-called "hate speech."
Now I say so-called
because at issue
is not racial slurs
or Holocaust denial,
but if we criminalize
hate speech,
we would essentially curtail
and to a large extent
forbid deliberation on
major political issues
confronting the country.
In the left's expansive
conception of hate speech,
calling for less immigration,
advocating for welfare reform,
opposing the transgender
agenda, or simply defending
the Christian
conception of marriage
could all be considered
forms of hate speech.
Let me put it to you bluntly.
Hate speech,
according to the left,
encompasses an awful lot of
Republican, conservative,
and Christian speech.
The Supreme Court, it
is true, has so far
stood strong on the
issue, but conservatives
must remain vigilant.
The court, after all, is not
bound by its own precedence,
and it will often
bow to public opinion
and change its mind on a whim.
Now, the left's
assault on free speech
goes well beyond restricting
what we are allowed to say.
The Democratic Party also wants
to further restrict our ability
to fund political speech by
enacting ever tighter campaign
finance restrictions.
The rhetoric they deploy
is quite seductive--
we want to have everyone
have an equal voice;
we want to end undue influence.
But the effectual
truth of such policies,
as Machiavelli
might say, would be
to give the media an
even more outsized voice
in influencing elections.
Because the press,
remember, is never
subject to campaign
finance laws.
And while they like
to speak of "earned
media" for the various
candidates, don't be fooled.
All media is bestowed
by the media.
The First Amendment, as
understood by the framers,
protects not just
your right to speak,
but your right to publish
and promote your views.
And a Republican Party
that wants to win
should therefore set its
sights on dismantling
most of the campaign
finance architecture
that has been built up in
America in the past four
decades.
We cannot win if we play by the
rules they rigged in their own
favor.
Lastly, the
Republicans really need
to take seriously, look into
the very credible accusations
that the major tech platforms--
Twitter, Facebook, and
in particular, Google--
are influencing our politics by
manipulating what information
Americans can see online.
Right now, Senators
Cruz and Hawley
are basically the
only two vocal voices
in the party who take
this threat seriously.
Big tech has a political agenda.
These are not just regular
for-profit corporations.
And that agenda is
not just progressive,
it is anti-conservative.
But their activities
and their algorithms
are shrouded in secrecy.
The Republican Party has
to wake up to the fact
that threats to liberty can
come from the private sector
and not just the state.
Second, looking at
the electoral system,
the Democratic Party wants to
transform our electoral system
to skew it in its favor.
And they want to do this
primarily by one of two ways.
The first is to make
it easier for anyone
to vote by essentially
eliminating
any safeguards on voter fraud.
Now concerns for
voter fraud, they
say, you know what they are?
They're racist dog whistles
to disenfranchise minorities.
Now I gotta tell you,
I'm not a citizen yet.
I'm working on it.
But as a foreigner
living in America,
that is the one thing I
absolutely cannot wrap my mind
about--
wrap my mound around--
[LAUGHTER]
--wrap my mind around about
this great country I so admire.
How in God's green Earth
can you allow people
to vote without showing ID?
How can you not demand proof of
citizenship when it comes time
to register?
[APPLAUSE]
And while I'm at
it, how do you not
check whether people
are registered
in more than one state?
It's surreal.
Even we silly Canadians
don't do this.
[LAUGHTER]
The Democratic Party basically
wants an honor system
when it comes to voting,
the result of it which
would be maximum fraud.
It therefore has to be a
top priority for the GOP,
especially at the
state level, to protect
the integrity of the ballot.
But the Democrats don't
just want everyone to vote,
including, by the way,
incarcerated felons.
You can thank Bernie Sanders and
the ACLU for that genius idea.
They also want to get rid
of that pesky Electoral
College that keeps on
allowing the GOP to steal
elections the way they
did in 2000 and 2016.
Therefore, they are actively
pushing the National Popular
Vote initiative.
It's now been adopted by
15 states and the District
of Columbia, and the left is
pouring millions of dollars
into this initiative
that must be countered.
Meanwhile, the Republican Party
has devoted more resources
to defending the
carried interest
loophole than to defending
the Electoral College.
Then there is this question
of demographic change.
So we conservatives love
to quote Andrew Breitbart.
You know the dictum, right?
Culture is upstream
from politics,
and this is our way
of excusing ourselves
for having lost so
much ground in America
over the past century.
But it seems to me
that this is not
how the left and the Democratic
Party look at things.
They seem to think that
demographics is upstream
from both culture and politics,
and that if they can change
the demographics of
the country, primarily
through large-scale
immigration, they can
secure a permanent majority.
Now, it's no secret that
immigrants and their children
overwhelmingly
vote for Democrats.
So when the Democrats say
diversity is our strength,
you better believe them.
It's just that the
our in the sentence
is not America, but
the Democratic Party.
And so they want to
abolish the border.
They want to attract even more
immigrants with the promise
of free health care
and a reassurance
that in America we
don't enforce our laws.
All of this paving the way
for a glorious amnesty that
would turn Texas, Florida,
and Arizona into California.
Now I'm not saying
that Republicans
should oppose all
immigration because of this.
I just think that, when
the enemy is giving you
his war plans, you'd be foolish
not to take them seriously.
I don't know what the future
demographics of the country
are, but I'm not a
Republican strategist.
What worries me is that
the Republican strategists
don't seem to think
about this either.
At the very least,
it seems to me
that Republicans should
hold the line strong
and oppose any and all amnesty.
The last time we
did amnesty in '86,
there were 5 million
illegals in this country.
Today, there are anywhere
between 11 and 29 million.
Now, I'll end by saying this--
these three priorities
are the bare minimum
if the GOP just wants
to hold the line,
if it wants to have a future.
But these are not going
to constitute a victory.
The GOP also needs to
go on the offensive,
and that really means
thinking like the left
and going after the centers
of power of the enemy.
And in this case,
it's the universities.
Hillsdale and a handful
of other colleges
excepted, our universities
are deeply, deeply corrupt.
They do not serve
the common good.
They do not promote
the discovery of truth.
They are not forming citizens
for Republican self-government.
They have largely
become madrassas
of higher indoctrination
that also function as the R&D
department for the left.
America needs a transformational
higher education reform agenda
aimed at dealing a devastating
blow to the universities
and the colleges.
First, the GOP should do to them
what Trump did to the media--
expose the charlatans
and humiliate them.
No more honoring of these
corrupt institutions.
Second, you go after the money.
America cannot continue to
subsidize these universities
to the tune of billions
of dollars a year.
That means--
[APPLAUSE]
In other words, give your
money to Hillsdale, not
to these universities.
[LAUGHTER]
By the way, that's the
thing for conservatives.
I'm always bewildered to see
red-blooded, patriotic, God
fearing conservatives giving
money to their alma mater.
Unless that alma mater is
one of a handful of schools
in this country that
take education seriously,
this is not the school
you went to 50 years ago.
We need to restrict
the $40 billion a year
we send to them
in research funds,
and we need to completely revamp
the government-backed student
loan industry.
I'll end by saying this.
I'll like to raise
the one question
I have so far not addressed,
and that, regrettably, I
won't have the time
to address because I'm
afraid of Anton, who wants
me to stick to my time.
And that is, what's the positive
thing that the Republican
Party should fight for?
And I think that the shortest
and broadest possible answer
has to be America.
The Republican Party should
be the party of Americans
who love America and
Americans, period.
The party of unabashed
patriotic pride
in the accomplishments
of this great country.
The party of Americans
who cling not just
to their guns and
their religion,
but to their capitalism, their
constitution, their land,
their borders, their past,
their language, their spirit.
The party of all those who see
themselves as Americans first.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ALLEN GUELZO: And
after the earthquake
a still, small voice.
[LAUGHTER]
When I was asked to speak to
this panel's topic, The Future
of the Republican Party,
the question which
came at once to my mind was,
why are you asking a historian?
Because my principal
preoccupation
is with understanding the past.
But in the spirit of
an earlier Republican,
who suggested that
if we could first
know where we are and
whither we are tending,
we could better judge what
to do and how to do it,
let me take the
historical turn anyway
and ask what the
Republican Party has
been from its origins
in the mid-1850s
before speculating on
what it will or should be.
What has made the
Republican Party?
We tend to identify the two
dominant political parties
by the policies
they espouse, either
through their
presidential candidates
or their national platforms.
And almost all that we have
heard thus far this morning
has been about
policies, which are all
about the present
and the immediate.
But that assumes that
all that makes a party
are its policy formulations.
If that were the
case, American history
should be populated by an
exuberance of third party
movements.
And it isn't.
This is because beneath
the easily visible shape
of policies there
exists, for both parties,
an iceberg-like
submergence of what may
be called political culture.
Political culture
provides each party
with its long-term ballast
of values and principles.
Policies form the tip of the
iceberg, the visible part.
Political culture is what
lies below the visible,
but gives it its
coherence and consistency.
This incidentally
is why third parties
tend to be so few
and so short-lived,
because third
parties are usually
the creatures of personalities,
or purely of policies
and have no ballast
of their own.
Political culture is the
longue durée of politics.
For every significant
policy issue,
Republicans and Democrats
have significantly different
answers.
But the difference lies in the
different political cultures
from which they have emerged.
So let us talk first about
the political cultures
of the parties,
and only then ask
what the future of the
Republican Party will be.
In its beginning will
be found its future.
The political culture
of the American parties
has been shaped around seven,
shall we say, arguments.
Those seven arguments
are the economic system,
the political center, morals,
style, occupation, family,
and philosophy.
For an economic system,
the democratic ideal
has always been stasis,
while the Republican word
has been mobility.
For the political center,
the guiding democratic notion
has been the tribal
or the local--
and that presents to us
today the form incidentally
of identity politics--
while the Republican alternative
has been the nation as a whole,
so that an American
identity is understood
as superior to a racial
or gendered identity.
For Democrats, morals
are matters of invention,
while for Republicans,
morals have been natural.
For Democrats, style
has been about passion,
while for Republicans,
style has been about reason.
The preferred
democratic occupation
has been subsistence,
and for Republicans, it
has been entrepreneurial.
The democratic concept of
family has been companionate,
while for Republicans,
family has been organic.
And in terms of
philosophy, Democrats
are the disciples,
even today, of Hegel
and the tribe of Hegel;
they are romantics,
while Republicans are the
disciples, even today,
of the moderate
enlightenment, which
is to say of Locke,
Madison, and Lincoln.
Understanding this yields
us the long-term insight
that we need to ask the
question of the hour
about the Republican
Party's future.
For in fact, the political
culture of the Republican Party
remains one of only two options
in American political life,
and will persist despite
the ephemera of policies.
But it will have to manage
those policies intelligently
and consistently with its
underlying political culture
if that future is to
be a successful one.
What will it take then
for the Republican Party
to build a successful future
out of its political culture?
For most of
republicanism's life,
as either the Republican Party
or as its forerunner, the Whig
Party, Democrats were
in effective control
of American policies.
That was true
during the long run
of the Jeffersonian/Jacksonian
Democrats from 1800 to 1860,
and during the even longer
run of progressive Democrats
from 1932 to 2016, with
the brief interregnum
of Ronald Reagan.
Under that shadow, we can
recognize fairly easily
the democratic
political culture that
has dictated democratic policy.
Begin with the first of my seven
arguments, the economic system.
Those of us here have
lived much of our lives
under the economic
direction of democrats.
And they, like their
Jacksonian forebears,
have preferred an
economy of stasis
in which an administrative
and corporate elite recruits
a proletarian class as its ally
in corralling and suppressing
the middle class, who are
the paragons of mobility
and are seen as dangerous,
precisely for aspiring
to mobility.
The evidence of this
is all around us.
Between 1940 and 2016,
economic mobility rates
in the United States have
declined from 92% to just 50%.
We are now as immobile a
society as the United Kingdom.
And while Democrats complain
about economic inequality,
they are the party who
benefits the most from it
and promotes the policies
most likely to ensure it.
Let us take New York
City as one example.
Although New York City has long
been as unanimously democratic
as any American center can
be, 1/5 of Gotham's residents
live below the poverty line.
The number of homeless
people in New York City
has increased by 37.4%
between 2007 and 2016.
Overall, no meaningful reduction
in poverty in New York City
has occurred in
the last 20 years.
That this seems to
cause modern Democrats
nothing beyond rhetorical
heartburn is plain.
Their concern about
inequality is at base a plea
for the reinstatement of stasis
since their forebears sneered
at economic mobility as a threat
to their economic privilege.
Republicans of an
earlier time knew
what this stasis was
called, and to it they
opposed the principles of
free labor and self-making.
So most Republicans of the
present day and the future.
The promotion of that mobility
also governed Republican policy
on trade.
Republicans inherited from
their Whig forerunners
a commitment to the protection
of American commerce,
whether agricultural
or manufacturing.
Although tariffs have
often been a bad word
in American political
life, that is
because tariffs were a bad word
first for Jacksonian democrats,
and then for Wilsonian
progressives.
Partly this was because free
trade progressives had already
adopted the notion of a
global economy in which
the fate of the
American producer
was held to be subordinate
to the overall global system,
and partly because
tariffs offered benefits
only to the upwardly mobile,
not to an elite who had already
arrived.
The founders in the first
Congress under the Constitution
had no hesitation about imposing
average tariffs of 81.5%.
It was under
Democratic leaderships
that tariffs were
lowered to just 20%,
while the first Republican
tariffs under Abraham Lincoln
once more rose to 49% and
stayed that way until the Wilson
administration.
The purpose of the tariff
for Republicans was simple--
encourage the development
of the domestic economy
by shielding it from the
economic warfare practiced
by the European powers.
But tariffs are
only one example,
and not even the most
pressing example,
of a larger
understanding Republicans
must have about the relationship
of government and the economy.
From the days of
Thomas Jefferson,
the democratic ethos has
always seen government
as the restrainer, critic,
and opponent of commerce,
and that fundamental
attitude has not changed.
It did not change on the
first panel this morning.
Republicans have understood
the role of government
as that of enabler, from
the days of Henry Clay
and his American system
of internal improvements
to Lincoln's sponsorship
of the Homestead Act,
the largest single
privatization of government
assets in American history,
and the Pacific Railway Act.
Latter day Republicans
will be in good company
if they understand
that commerce is
as much a matter of
national security as drones
and missiles.
The Republican
future will also rest
on a reawakening to the
importance of morals and family
to its identity.
The prevailing nihilism,
which reduces all politics
to considerations
of power and places
government regulatory authority
at the center of society
rather than families and
mediating institutions,
bodes well neither for
the Republican Party
nor for the republic itself.
The Republicans of the 1860s
made their rallying cry
against slavery an
appeal to natural rights
and the centrality of the
family and marriage bond.
We have put legalized
slavery long behind us,
but the arguments that the
slave holding oligarchs used
to defend slavery
have eerie valences
to those today used to
promote abortion on demand,
indifference to the
flourishing of families,
and the centralization of social
authority in an amoral elite.
Republicans of
today and tomorrow
must find their way back to a
national ethic of natural law
morality, and with
it, a healthy division
of power between the state and
civil society, which is to say,
rediscovering their
political culture.
It has been said that
Republicans cannot hope to make
a case for these principles in
the face of a revolutionary new
American demographic.
Yet Republicans were facing
an even more revolutionary
demographic in the 1860s
when totally unrestrained
immigration enabled new
demographic groups--
Irish, Italians, Germans--
to approach the thresholds
of political power.
Yet Republicans triumphed
because while immigrant groups
begin with very
distinct identities,
the promotion of intermarriage
and economic mobility
gradually erased
those distinctives.
Today we are witness
to a substantial growth
in Asian and Latino
voters, whom it
is feared Republicans have
lost to the blandishments
of their Democratic opponents.
But Latino voters
over two generations
gradually lose their sense
of Hispanic particularity.
By the third and
fourth generation
of Latino immigrants,
as high as 50% no longer
identify themselves as Latino,
but simply as American.
Thus, the Hispanic
and Asian electorates,
precisely because they are in
a state of generational flux,
by no means spell the end
of a Republican future
any more than did their European
predecessors a century or more
before.
Already among African-Americans,
a generational shift
is apparent as younger
African-Americans in 2016
pulled noticeably shy of
democratic progressives
and continue to do so
in their chilliness
toward Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren.
But the predictability
of this in turn
depends for Republicans on a
reappropriation and promotion
of its own political culture.
I could perhaps go on
further into reexamining
the philosophy, the
style, the occupation
of Republican political culture.
But as Jebediah
Nightlinger immortally
admitted, while I have the
inclination, the maturity,
and the wherewithal,
unfortunately, I
don't have the time.
[LAUGHTER]
It is worth saying, however,
that the most curiously
encouraging note for
the Republican future
has been the vanishing of
democratic complacency.
It was a trademark of
the Democratic Party
ever since the New Deal that
the future was understood
to be inexorably bending
in its direction,
and that the task
of its intellectuals
was to silence
complaints about elitism
and the effacement of
democracy by identity politics.
The election of 2016 and
the corresponding lurch
of the Democratic Party
beyond progressivism
toward European style
social democracy
should be seen for what it is--
an ominous admission
of terror at the revolt
of the deplorables.
The Republican Party is
the only political entity
which can speak to this
revolt. If it does not,
the restless will turn
instead to authoritarianism,
and what we will get is what
Ivan Ilyin, the inspiration
of Vladimir Putin, calls
sovereign democracy, in which
the state is unified
and centralized,
its authority ceded
to an individual,
and that individual
glamorized and glorified by
centralization, personification,
and idealization.
To resist that
temptation, Republicans
must find their
future in their past.
The battle that began against
romantic oligarchy in 1861
is not over.
The truth is, we're
only in the third round.
[APPLAUSE]
HENRY OLSEN: Thank
you very much.
I want to let you know that
The Washington Post explicitly
hired me to provide some
balance for their page, which
means on any given day I'm
outnumbered only 9 to 1,
which is right
where I want them.
Being at a Hillsdale
Institute, Hillsdale event
reminds me that Hillsdale's
intellectual legacy
is descended in modern
times to its president Larry
Arnn from that of his
alma mater, Claremont.
And it would be
ill becoming of me
to attend anything inspired
by Claremont without quoting
either Aristotle or Lincoln.
In this case, there are
three appropriate quotes
that I'd like to start
with because they frame
very nicely what I think
the political challenge
of the Republican Party is.
First, from the
Nicomachean Ethics,
where Aristotle talks about
all activity having an end,
and he says that in
strategy, the end is victory.
So that for any
political party that
engages in strategy, no
less than any army, the aim
must be to win in politics.
In democratic politics,
that means to win elections.
So then the question is,
how does one win elections
in a modern democracy?
Well, Abraham Lincoln
provides this quote for that.
In 1858, he said that public
sentiment is everything.
With it, nothing is forbidden,
and without it, nothing
can be obtained.
And he went ahead and
proved that to himself
in a private letter,
which was now
part of the collection
of Lincoln writings,
in which he wrote to himself
not words, but numbers.
Recall that, in
1858, senators were
elected not directly by
the vote of the people,
but through the legislature.
So what he needed
to do was to win
a majority of state legislators
who were to be elected.
And this letter
contains two columns--
one, district by
district the votes
for the presidential
race, which was
three ways between a Republican,
a Democrat, and Millard
Fillmore, the Know
Nothing or American Party
candidate, and the other,
the race for governor, which
was a two-way, or
another race, which
was a two-way race between
Democrats and Republicans.
And through this
what he determined
was that the way to victory was
to persuade Know Nothings, who
obviously were not persuaded
by pure Republican rhetoric,
to join with the Republican
cause, for if he could do that,
he could theoretically
win the majority.
So the question for us
then is to assess strength.
The question is, what is
public sentiment today?
Do we constitute a majority?
And if not, how
do we obtain one?
Anything else from
a political matter
simply pales into
insignificance.
So the first thing
to recognize is
movement conservatives,
to use the broad term,
are not a majority.
In fact, they're
not even a majority
of the Republican Party.
I wrote a book on
this called The Four
Faces of the
Republican Party, which
looked at 20 years of exit
poll data prior to Trump.
And you can conclusively
see that that union
that Ted Cruz so dearly wished
for between Libertarians
and Tea Partiers and
religious right establishment
was at most a third of
the Republican Party's
national electorate.
In fact, Cruz successfully
obtained his goal
and had exactly
the end I predicted
for him in a series of
National Review essays
going back to 2014--
defeat.
He would have lost to
any sentient Republican
because the majority
of the Republican Party
exists between the
moderates who remain voters
in presidential primaries, even
as they are not strong enough
in many of their homes, like
the San Francisco Bay area, New
York City, and Boston to send
representatives to Congress,
and the group that tells
pollsters they are somewhat
conservative, which
in a short word
says the people who preferred
John Boehner and Mitch
McConnell to Ted
Cruz or Mike Lee.
We also know that
they're not a majority,
even when they contain control
of a Republican electorate
over broader Republican
constituencies.
Take the examples
of Sam Brownback
and the current battles
going on in Alaska.
Sam Brownback was
governor of Nebraska,
about his deep red a
state as you can get.
He pushed through
a supply side tax
cut praised by the Americans
for Tax Reform and virtually
every right thinking
intellectual on economic policy
in the Republican Party.
And four years later,
he was defeated
within Republican primaries
by Republican moderates
and somewhat
conservatives who did not
like the cuts that
this loss of revenue
required to public services.
And they joined with
Democrats to override
the governor's veto repealing
the entirety of his tax cuts.
We're going through the
same battle in Alaska
right now, where the
Governor Mike Dunleavy has
said to Alaska
voters, you've been
spending beyond your means
for years, you must cut back,
and by doing that, I will
restore your annual check
from the dividend fund of Alaska
and give you each $1,400 more.
Now, think about that.
What he's saying is that
if you restrain spending,
every family of four
will get $5,600 a year.
That is larger than any tax
cut that any Republican has
proposed in the last 60 years.
And yet he sits underwater
in personal opinion ratings,
he's under 40%, and
there's a massive recall
that is forming right now
to remove him from office.
Even in red Alaska,
people will not
choose the Republican
movement conservative economic
philosophy.
So where is public sentiment
if it is not on the right?
Well, we can look
at public sentiment
by looking at its voter groups
that swing between the parties,
because it is clear that it
is not democratic either.
The Republican Party is
behind the Democratic Party
in identification, but
the Democratic Party,
unlike the days of
the '50s and the '60s
and the '70s when they could
command over half of America
as a default party loyalist,
sits barely in the 30s
when asked the hard question,
and only into the 40s
when asked it in a soft way.
The Democratic Party thinks
it represents the majority,
but it in fact, like the
Republican Party of old,
only represents the
largest mobilized minority.
We can divide the swing
voters into three groups
if we think of it
as a menagerie.
The Republicans
are the elephants,
which should say, combining
all species of movement
conservative with their
more moderate Boehnerite
and McConnell-like brethren.
These are the elephants.
There are three swing
groups in American politics.
The two that are
most prominent today
I called rhinos and tigers.
Rhinos are Republicans
in name only.
They are suburban, educated,
upper income Republicans.
These are the people who tended
to defect to Hillary Clinton,
but remained resolutely
unsocialist in their economics.
And even if they inclined
towards some degree
of social liberalism,
are not wholly
in the board of the
transformationalist
progressives who wish to
undo centuries of morality.
The tigers are the group
that Donald Trump attracts.
I call them TIGRs because
it stands for Trump Is Great
Republicans.
Gotta be creative
in my business.
These are the people who
tend to be blue collar.
They tend to be native
born, although there
are more minorities here
than you would believe
if you listened to the media.
They tend to be groups that
move towards Donald Trump
precisely because he was the
only Republican in decades
to respond to what Bill
Galston and others spoke
about on the first
panel, which is
the realities of
economic life today.
They like protection.
They like protection
from foreign labor,
whether it's through
immigration restriction or trade
restriction.
They like protection from
economic vicissitudes,
which is why Donald Trump's
pledge that, unlike Paul Ryan,
he was not going to touch
Social Security and Medicare
was absolutely crucial to
winning these voters over.
And they came in droves.
There were over
seven million people
who voted for President Obama
who voted for Donald Trump,
and a million to
three million more
who came from the
rolls of the not
voting into the Republican
rolls to elect Donald Trump.
They are also the reason
he swept the primary,
that the Republican turnout in
the 2016 primaries and caucuses
nearly equaled democratic for
the first time in history.
It was not until
the last weekend
of voting when California voted
that the democratic turnout
finally exceeded the
Republican turnout.
People voted in the
Republican primary for Trump
who had never voted
for any Republican
in any presidential
primary before.
How do you bring the rhinos
and the tigers together?
Well, the rhinos are
the sort of people
who are supportive of
capitalist economics,
but capitalism with what
you might call a human face.
They are supportive
of economic cuts.
They would favor
economy in government,
but not the wholesale
unraveling of it.
They are in favor of
the traditional family.
But they are not in favor
of the return to the 1950s.
They are not in
favor of a return
to a de facto Christian America
where views on sex and gender
roles are dictated by
traditional views taken
from the traditional
view of the Bible.
They are moderates
in that sense,
neither wholly with progressives
nor wholly with conservatives
on the culture war.
Tigers, on the
other hand, are what
are called morally moderate.
They will revolt on
culture wars only when
they see themselves
directly skewered
by one side or the other.
These are people who
like Donald Trump
but did not like Mike
Huckabee in 2008.
These are people who do not
like being called deplorables
and do not like having
their way of life
attacked daily in the media
or by democratic leaders.
This is why sane
Democrats are hoping
that Joe Biden can be the
nominee because he's not
threatening to these people
on a cultural dynamic.
But these are people
who want protection.
These are the sort of people
who wanted worker safety
laws and workman
compensation back
in the 1900s and the 1910s.
These are the people who were
the party of the New Deal
and interpreted the New Deal
not in a socialist manner
but in a humane reforming
of capitalism manner.
These are the people who
benefited from FHA loans.
benefited from expansions
of public universities.
These are the people for
whom Medicare and Social
Security are the massive
anchors on which they
rest their future,
non-working lives.
They do not expect to depend
on family, a family which
would be unlikely to support
them if these things were gone.
They do not depend on
local institutions.
They depend on Social
Security and Medicare
for a comfortable,
dignified retirement.
A Republican Party
that can speak to these
is a Republican Party
that can gain them.
Right now, we have two
Republican parties,
both of which are essentially
warring over minority
coalitions.
The Trump coalition, which is
the elephants plus the tigers,
is a coalition that is
electorally efficient
because tigers tend to
live in the Upper Midwest,
and they can swing
the electoral college.
And because of the way
our Senate is elected,
you can have pretty much
a lock on the Senate,
as long as you have an
elephant and tiger majority.
You cannot win the House with
this majority because it has
nothing to the rhinos that swung
the house over to the Democrats
last time.
The traditional Republican
Party effectively
wants a rhino plus
elephant coalition.
This is the Romney coalition.
This was the Paul
Ryan coalition.
This was a coalition that
can deliver the house
and deliver it rather well,
even without gerrymandering.
It may not be a large majority,
but it is a decent chance
to have a long-term majority.
It is one for which
the Senate is a coin
flip because it is more
suburban and it is less rural.
And it is one that has no hope
of winning the presidency.
They claim otherwise, but I only
have two minutes and 30 seconds
and I don't want to spend it
demolishing their argument.
The short-term
Republican majority
is to combine the three
together-- rhinos, tigers,
and elephants, oh my.
This is something that a
modified Trumpism, one shorn
of the president's
distinctive negative aspects
of his personality, but one
that is more open to what I call
a limited and energetic
government, one that
is willing to act,
not simply stand back
in the face of the realities
of the modern economic state,
and one that values security
as in equal measure to liberty
and opportunity, that is
where the majority is.
And that is something that a
left wing influence did not
dominate the Democratic Party
would have very difficult time
competing against.
The last group is one that
I've never mentioned before--
Michael gets a
new animal today--
and that is the ram.
What is a RAM?
The Recently Arrived Minority.
See, I had to have a nice
animal for immigrants.
Who are the rams?
The rams are unlike
other immigrant groups.
And in our history, they are
distinctly Asian and from Latin
and South America.
A non-trivial
number from Africa.
What they are is perhaps
the least Christian
of any of our immigrant groups.
Hispanics are dramatically
lapsed Catholics.
And virtually no
Asian immigrant comes
from a Christian background.
They are also from more
collectivist backgrounds.
And this they do share in
common with the second wave
of immigration, the people
from Italians and Eastern
Europe who shaped the 1880
to 1820 migration wave.
They will over time become
assimilated to American ways
of life and consequently be
more open to American arguments.
But the fact remains that
even today the grandchildren
and the great grandchildren
of the immigrants of that wave
are much more open to
economic intervention
than the wave of people
who are descended
from native British
Protestant stock.
A Republican Party that wants to
engage with demographic change
has to engage with the
rams on their own turf.
In that sense, they are merely
a different manifestation
of the challenge of engaging
with rhinos and tigers.
And it is perhaps
an act of hutzpah
to invoke the name of Lincoln
with Allen Guelzo sitting
to the right of me.
But I think that
the Republicanism
of Lincoln and Reagan, one
of a limited but energetic
government, one that sees
action and inaction as two
sides of the same coin
with the thumb firmly
on the scales of liberty,
but not so firmly
on the scales of liberty to
leave one blind to reality,
that one can engage with this.
And if one does
this, then I think
there is a more than passing
chance that the Republican
Party can do something it has
not been able to do since 1928,
and that is to
genuinely say that they
command the plurality, if
not the majority, support
of the voters the United
States of America.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL ANTON: Here we go.
So being the chair, I get to
ask the first questions, one
of the privileges
of being the chair.
Now, I'm going to try to
split the difference in a way
from the presentations
I have heard,
take a little bit from
each, and then see
how they respond to this.
So starting with Dave.
When I look at the
recent electoral numbers,
I think Azerrad is
of course correct
that recent immigrants and
their immediate descendants
from the post-1965
wave tended to vote
in rough terms
two-to-one democratic.
And so if the demographic
change continues
the way it's
changing, that doesn't
spell great electoral things
for the Republican Party.
And to quote Marco Rubio
from one of the 2016 debates,
"they know exactly
what they're doing."
That is, the Democrats
who are pushing this,
opposing the wall, opposing
any kind of reform,
and in fact getting
more radical as we
watch the democratic debates
in this season-- getting
more radical in their insistence
that the country just simply
has to be wide open
to anyone forever.
On the other hand,
Professor Guelzo
is certainly correct
that the United States
has undergone significant
demographic change very rapidly
in high numbers in the
past, and has successfully
assimilated these populations
and turned many of them
Republican.
In fact, built Republican
majorities in part
on the strength of voting
patterns of recent immigrants,
or at least their descendants
one or two generations down.
So during the 2016
campaign, one of the things
that I'll be just
blunt and confess,
I was a fairly early
Trump supporter.
I wasn't one of
those who at the end
had to hold my nose
and vote for him.
I did it sort of
enthusiastically.
And one of the
reasons for that was I
thought, well, he's breaking
the old Republican mode where
the working class, the lower
middle class, the blue collar,
the non-college educated,
sees the Republican
Party as simply just out to get
them, not for their interests.
The party of finance,
the party of outsourcing,
the party of cutting
benefits, as Henry mentioned.
And that party had a
very limited appeal,
to say the least,
to this demographic.
So it seemed like Trump
was the first to come along
who was really going to
break that mold, maybe
with the prospect of a
long-term realignment
of that economic segment
of the electorate aligning
with the Republican Party.
But given the reality
of demographic change,
as it's ongoing in this
country, the Republican Party
could maybe
successfully do that,
but it won't successfully win
elections or build a majority
unless it can get a
pretty significant chunk.
It doesn't have to be 50%,
but a pretty significant chunk
of Black, Hispanic, blue collar
workers, voters, and so on.
And so if the goal is to get
to at least a plurality that's
bigger than the other guy's
plurality, or even better yet,
an enduring majority
in the low to mid-50's,
the Republican Party
has to do that.
Or I just don't see how it
survives as a party that
can win national elections.
So my quick question then
for all three panelists
is, what are the
prospects for success.
And if you're the chair of
the RNC, what do you do?
What are the things that
you would put in place,
have the party do, in order to
make that success more likely?
We'll just go in order, I think.
DAVID AZERRAD: I don't
have a proper answer
to that serious and
important question, Mike.
And I'm not speaking for the
Heritage Foundation here.
I'm speaking as a Canadian
immigrant to the US.
What gives me pause
about immigration is not
the immigrants--
it's the elites.
I mean, this is just
not our country anymore.
Immigrants will assimilate.
You have no choice
but to assimilate.
The issue is
assimilate into what?
Into Howard Zinn's
America, going
into our schools,
our university,
our general cultural,
teaching them
that this is the country
that invented slavery
and Jim Crow that
is irredeemably
racist and sexist
and homophobic,
encouraging them to
think of themselves
as hyphenated Americans because
that's where the goodies are
from the government, the racial
preferences, the handouts,
the you name it?
There is an anecdote I like to
share that Indians from India
petitioned the Reagan
administration to be
reclassified as Asians.
They were classified as Whites.
They demanded to be Asians.
Why?
Because there are government
benefits if you are a minority.
You get special loans from
minority-owned businesses.
So I am very much in favor
of slowing down immigration
because I do not trust in us, in
our capacity, in our willpower,
to assimilate immigrants
into Americanness.
And independently of any
electoral considerations,
that gives me a lot of pause.
Until we regain confidence,
until we reconquer
the institutions we
lost to the left,
we're asking to simply
swell the ranks of people
who are not going to think in
the right American way because
of us.
I think they may come here
with the best of intentions.
We're going to encourage
them to go the other way.
ALLEN GUELZO: Couple of
thoughts come to mind here.
Invoking Lincoln
on public sentiment
is an interesting
way of understanding
Lincoln as a political figure.
Public sentiment, he
said, is everything.
With it, you can do
a great many things.
Without it, nothing.
But he did not regard
himself as being passive
in the face of public sentiment.
When he talked about
public sentiment that way,
his idea was you shape
public sentiment.
And you shape it around
a certain set of values.
One does not see
him in the debates
against Stephen Douglas
attempting to temperize,
to modify, to tone down.
If anything, over the course
of the seven debates of 1858,
Lincoln becomes more trenchant.
He becomes sharper.
So that by the last two of
the great debates of 1858,
Lincoln is now speaking
in broad, great terms
about the principles
that are at stake,
in slavery versus freedom.
And he does not hesitate
to compare slavery
to the rule of kings.
He says, it really
doesn't matter
whether you're talking
about a king who
seeks to bestride the
people of his own nation
and live by the
fruit of their labor,
or one race of men as an apology
for enslaving another race.
It is the same
tyrannical principle.
He believed in shaping
public opinion.
And he believed the
long-term shaping was
going to make the difference.
[FIRE ALARM]
SPEAKER: May I have
your attention, please.